[Music]
What's up, guys? I'm going to be showing
you an free-to-play moneymaking guide
that's very easy and very simple and has
no requirements. So, start Alcarid in
the plate shop right there and go ahead
and trade him. And you're going to go
ahead and buy all the bronze plate legs
because they only get up to about 84
coins and um they start at 80 so it's
not that big a deal. And then go ahead
and switch worlds. Um, I know I'm using
members worlds, but you can easily just
use the freetoplay worlds as no one ever
buys them
and go ahead see the value.
See, and then go buy them all. And then
just continue doing this and then sell
them the GE. All right. So once you're
done, head to the GE. And I bought about
a hundred of them in four minutes. So
it's very quick.
And these can sell for about I think
almost 500 coin. Yeah,$4.99. But um
we'll just sell let's sell one of them.
Let's just try 450 just to see if we can
instant sell.
Yep. Okay. So we'll go ahead and sell
all these for 450.
So they instantly sold.
So that took about four minutes.
So let's do 100.
times 85 because that's about how much
they cost.
And we'll go ahead and do the 45K that
we made
and minus the 8,500 that it cost. So
36.5K.
So we'll do 60 minutes divided by the
four minutes that took us 15. So 15 time
36.5K.
And we're left with 550K. So, if you
sell for max price at 600K, and this can
be used as a free-to-play method, and it
can help you guys get that bond in no
time. All right, thanks for watching,
guys.
[Music]